here we go so we are here with Professor
Jim Hughes it's an absolute honor to
have you on mlst Jen thank you so much
for coming on it's a pleasure amazing um
so um you're a professor of Gene
regulation at Oxford University yeah and
um you said that you studied the basic
biology of how genes are regulated in
the mammalian genome in concert with how
sequence variation in the human
population affects this and predisposes
towards disease yep that's a summary I
think everything website
tell me I mean obviously like we're
we're a machine learning and AI podcast
yeah and we're at a creativity
um event yeah and you know maybe like
talk about
why are you here today what are you
talking about here today
um okay maybe just a little bit of
History so I've been working in the
genome for 30 years pretty much Madame
boy yeah and I started off
um as a bench person very much working
in cloning bits of genome doing all of
that kind of stuff yeah
um by the time the genome got sequenced
which was about 10 years into that so
it's like 2002 thereabouts
um we realize that a very small amount
of the genome was actually genes and
actually it's huge that's the other
problem and so then I started shifting
into a computational side so I started
to learn to code do statistics you know
write packages do all that kind of stuff
um and so this is just kind of the full
extension of it now after 20 years I've
got a research Group which has got
um JavaScript programmers machine
learning people people from mathematics
backgrounds people cloning things doing
molecular experiments yeah so it's just
kind of tracked my life that I ended up
being a computer
sort of biologist so yes if you want to
put it that way
um why well I mean science is very
creative I mean it is necessarily A
Creative thing I mean people often think
of scientists as quite sort of logically
minded and
well yes we are I mean there's a big
burden of proof
letting me do but actually to actually
get to the next step we have to be
creative at the same time yes often I
will be coming up with new ideas new
hypotheses but also new methods so a lot
of what I'm known for in my field is
developing new molecular methods things
you can do at the bench but we also
develop new computational methods like
machine learning models just to try and
work out how these things work because
you know we have three billion base
pairs in our genome and they're working
differently in every single cell type in
our body and we don't know how many cell
types is actually in our body yes so the
human brain just ran out of steam quite
a long time ago so we needed to go to
these approaches what does it mean to be
creative
and ask them what's a really good talk
by Edwin I'm trying to remember it's
like an airline about what creative
means yes in my view it's he said
something about noise in the brain right
and that makes a lot of sense to me if
everything's really stable you never
really shift from one state to another
yeah where I think creativity comes from
is letting things Collide in your brain
having a slightly messy brain with signs
of strange things for a scientist to say
but I think that's what it is I think
you have a messy brain things just bump
into each other a lot you go do they
connect do they not connect could I do
this so different things bumping around
in your brain in a sort of semi-messy
way is probably my own internal Logic
for creativity interesting so I mean
going back to like you know the
cognitive scientists in the 80s like
Photo and pollution thought we had this
language of thought yeah and that you
know we
there's this kind of Primacy to logical
reasoning if you like rather than it
being some kind of post-hoc
rationalization I mean do you think it's
a post-hoc rationalization
um
probably a bit of both to some degree
because the you know
we our own personalities are the model
of what we were I mean that's how we
rationalize ourselves yes and I think
any model that we make whether it's a
scientific hypothesis or the world
around us or who are friends or you know
all of that kind of stuff is basically
us trying to make sense of the stuff
that happened behind us so I think
there's always a sort of post Hawk
not rationalization refinement
integration is probably a better way to
put it yes that's how it feels like to
me yes
you know like um we have these language
models
um how regular are we are we very
predictable
as humans yeah
um by all the humans yes because we're
the same system and we I think we're
pretty good at reading cues we're always
getting constant inputs from people like
we're looking at each other now across
the microphones you know what what is
the state of his mind how is he feeling
is he happy all of that stuff's going in
all the time yeah trying to get a
machine to predict that
that's a different thing I think because
you think of the training course we've
had all the way from like you know one
month old lying in a nappy up to our
daily professional experiences we're
constantly learning how the nuance and
read people and project ourselves as
well yes yeah because you can see that
that two ways because I I love the um
the tradition in cognitive science that
there's a there's an Ecology of
cognition you know that we're socially
embedded and and all the rest of it but
um so you can think of that two ways
like in in one sense it adds constraints
which does it has a regularizing
pressure which is pretty important in a
society yes yes but there's but there's
still potential for open-ended
exploration and diversity all over the
place it must be a balance between the
two you can't be completely chaotic and
you can't be completely stable because
if you're completely chaotic I mean
society would be not a lot of fun but if
you're completely stable then nothing
really changes and you know Evolution as
a society wouldn't really happen so
things like machine learning wouldn't
really come out if we were completely
regularized stable intellects yeah I've
never really think of all of the kind of
weird and wacky stuff that drives
um Human Society that's so true you know
protect of the Matrix said that you know
the first iterations were perfect oh yes
the first one was a very good film
I know I know what happened what
happened
um but but yeah so we exist on the kind
of boundary between order and you know
it's like the ying and a Yang yeah yeah
yeah and then you have the sort of the
learys of this world who want to kind of
dope that yeah to go beyond the bonus
I'm not right I wouldn't really suggest
that yes yeah maybe a strong cup of
coffee and a you know maybe a pint of
beers probably about as much as I want
to dope my intellect yes yes
um so I mean I I did a module in
bioinformatics on my computer science
degree and it was by far the most
interesting and algorithmic you know
about the turbi and like lots of dynamic
programming algorithms and multiple
sequence alignment all this kind of
stuff and I mean you're solving a really
really difficult problems right yeah so
from a tech algorithm point of view like
what are your weapons of choice
in terms of language well nothing I mean
just yeah algorithms compute
architectures I mean how are you how are
you attacking this problem
well I mean it depends there's
what you just mentioned sequence
alignment I think that's just a
classical statistical
um alignment process trying to get the
best match between something that's data
processing that's a very different thing
I mean so there's a couple of different
things we have to do one is I mean if
you think about it took coming by longer
took the sequence the human genome we
can sequence one over now and 100 and
with it you know so that level of data
flow Deluge is run by automated scripts
doing basic stuff like aligning the gene
I'm calling interesting places all of
that kind of stuff is the meat and
potatoes is what you have to do and it's
very complex and you have to get it
right
but then trying to
understand function from that is a
totally different boost and so one of
the things I always wanted to do was to
understand the encoding and that's
actually what my talk was about today
how is function encoded in the genome
not the genes
that I give up when they sequence the
genome like that's fine I did that off
to something else it's how are they
controlled because basically your cells
are turning these things on and off in a
very programmed manner noisy but
programmed yeah and so there was stuff
doing that so what was doing that and
the fact that we find you know three
percent of the genome codes for protein
that's that's that's the hard solid bit
of this what's all the rest of it people
said it was junk which was a very bad
idea because it's certainly not junk but
then how do you encode
function into that how did it involve
and that's the problem with Biology is
you're always trying to unpick a billion
year long set of accidents yes you know
so to try and do that with basic
statistical processes was just not easy
or even feasible so the things I work on
are called enhancers they're literally
bits of DNA in your genome and proteins
called transcription factors which are
expressed in different combinations to
sort of produced in different
combinations and different cell types
and different situations cooperate to
bind to that piece yeah and then they
become a switch
and then that switch
in a pretty unknown way can turn on a
gene in that it will make it produce
more of this RNA which is the the
intermediate bit that goes on make
protein yes so you'll have switches to
turn on hemoglobin in your red blood
cells that's why they're red in your eye
you'll have switches that turn on
crystalline which is the main you know
transparent part of your eye so how does
that happen
so what we we knew the basic idea and
people thought it was actually quite a
rare thing to have this switch and they
were known
these new methodologies that people
developed which were powered by this
next Generation sequencing Boom the fact
that we can sequence millions and
millions of sequences like the drop of a
heart yeah basically means we could
actually make maps of these things and
they're everywhere and they're switching
each cell type could almost be
barcoded by its set of switches it's
Unique to that that cell type and so
if if you think about it every cell type
in your body like I say I don't know how
many we've got we don't know has a
different encoded language in it yeah so
the encoding for one cell type is
different to the next and different to
the next so you're not breaking one code
you're breaking multiple if not
thousands of dynamic codes
simultaneously why is that
the way it's evolved I mean basically
what the what the genome has to do in
his job is when one cell type becomes
another and you started off as one cell
so by definition you have to become lots
of different cells so as it becomes
different cells it has to turn different
Gene zones in different combinations
that's that's how you do it yes but I
guess like but in a way I'm thinking
it's a bit like geological strata but
it's not it's much more complicated and
it's massively dynamic as well yeah
because they also talk to each other
yeah I mean this is really fascinating
because I can see an analogy to um to
machine learning and even cognitive
science I mean I was talking to a
mechanistic interpretability engineer
the other day and they're trying to
understand circuits and neural networks
and it's ridiculously complicated
because you identify a circuit like an
induction head and you turn it off and
then the network will kind of like adapt
and another circuit will take over the
job of that circuit and then you're
talking about function again in
intelligence and cognitive science
um you have like function Dynamics and
behavior right and like it's really
really divorce like function is divorced
from the underlying code in some way I
mean it's actually pretty analogous
because what you have is
events behaviors going on all of the
time but the actual
final product us and our behaviors is
such an emerging property yeah of many
many layers I'm right down on the very
basic letter now so I'm it's where the
code's being read that's why I'm working
yes you think about everything else that
comes out of that how once you've made
these proteins they go off and talk to
each other and how they fold you have
things like Alpha fault which was a
massive solution to that problem but
then they have to talk to each other and
they do it dynamically and they prefer
to well talk to this one more when this
one's here and then when they're
together they go and do another thing
and the complexity of that is immense
but even in my level the complexity was
so immense that there was no way I was
trying to learn the code of a tiny
little bit of genome for a very long
time and we could never do it using that
even the old school old school different
non-neural network based or machine
learning approaches just could not do it
yes neural networks basic convolutional
neural network cracked more or less
immediately really not perfectly yeah
but by God I mean you just went wow I
mean it was and that's when I became
Born Again deeply on that work because
it's the only thing that could pick
that signal light and the important
thing about it is the human genome is
huge yeah so when you do one of these
assays that we do and I I described it
in my talk as etching The genome or
you're DNA is all wrapped up in protein
there's about two meters of it in each
cell I mean that's a huge part of
information crowned into a tiny space
but it's wrapped up in these protective
um uh sets of proteins called
nucleosomes but they're not just
protective they're actually the access
point as well so you need to move them
away to access the bit of DNA so they
that's how you that's how those switches
work they actually there's a structural
and Regulatory
and you can actually do an RC called but
there's one called ataxicmon called DNA
C it doesn't really matter what they are
is the analogous of
etching a glass plate so if you take a
glass plate and you cover it in wax then
scrape a design on it and then put
hydrofluoric acid on it even for a bit
and wash it all off very carefully
nasty stuff you would have an edge on it
and so these assays are actually etching
for so you isolate a cell type you know
like a fibroblasts in your skin cells
the thing that makes you you know
connective tissue yeah so you isolate
that in the lab and then you expose the
nucleus to essentially a molecular
version of that that um acid and what it
will do is it will chop up the genome
into little bit where it doesn't have
this packing on it and that gives you a
complete map of where all these switches
are in the genome for the first time
and that is a perfect input for deep
neural networks
because you know you said that the
convolutional neural network just got it
and
in a way
are you are you kind of like depressed
that there are there's so much structure
there's so many so many patterns out
there that we can't understand and even
when we have a language model we have a
convolution on your own network it does
it but we don't know how
yes and we are always one validation is
absolutely critical to any use like this
I mean there's you know artistic you
know things are like dally too or
whatever the validation is I like the
look of it or it's a convincing
photograph yeah this is the science yes
so this has to be validated yes so when
you don't understand how it does it it
makes you deeply nervous
but you can validate is it doing its job
and so it's a halfway measurement we're
going if we can validate it and it's
doing what we want and we can validate
it as doing what we want
it does make me nervous that we don't
understand quite how it's doing it but
we are willing to use it while thinking
about ways of using I mean what we
simply do is we don't develop neural
network Technologies ourselves you know
in terms of like you know lstms or
whatever else we literally because
everybody's generating these things for
us we go oh that might work and we take
it in and we try it yeah so we're
looking at these more sort of
interpretable
sort of types of
Frameworks going as well but there's a
little bit in that it could do it
beforehand can't do it now I'll worry
about that a bit later as long as I can
validate I know it's a strange world we
live in because um you know language
models are getting quite reliable but
there's always that lingering doubt and
I mean with language models people just
when you generate content about
something you're not an expert and you
miss the errors and I think
interpretability on these large models
is a bit of a myth it doesn't really
exist yeah I mean just take a a dog
classifier yeah and even on a 100 pixel
squared RGB 8-bit
um how many combinations have you got
it's like it's ridiculous I mean like
you've got no hope in Hell of ever being
I mean what are you going to do you're
just you're gonna like it's like with
software we don't understand how
software works yeah and especially if
it's a large piece of software so we
write tests yeah and it's exactly
analogous but we do it at the bench
we write tests but we they're
experimental yes yes
um I mean I'll cover who was any
technology that because
it is pretty much that case yeah that's
where we are yeah
um but but but then you know like um
Chomsky says that language models aren't
a theory of linguistics and like by the
same token I mean as a scientist aren't
you looking for intelligible theories
yes there's there's two sides of it one
is just trying to understand a basic
encoding I mean if you think about what
I'm trying to do and many other people
are trying to do as well is we're just
trying to understand the basic code you
know it's not because it was it was
developed by Evolution so we have no
idea how it got to be like it is so
we're always reverse engineering to try
and understand what went on there yeah
and so any tool at that point will help
us because then once we can actually
understand the principles then we can
start thinking about the
um the hypotheses the biological bigger
hypotheses out of it but there's no way
you can hypothesize about the input of
data yes and and you know there's the
niches and the scruffies you know like
the the needs of searching for a simple
intelligible parsimonious Universal
underlying principle yeah and the
scruffies are just like oh it's just so
ridiculously complicated you'll never
understand it
um it's a difference between physicists
and biologists
physicists want that very very clean you
know equation yes and me and you are
basically evolutionary car crashes yeah
you know we happened because of many
many Random Encounters and pressures and
you just you know you just there's no
way you can never get back to the
finding principle of that yes we are an
emergent property of three billion years
of life yes so it can never be
reconstructed all you can do can be
deconstructed to understand how basic
bits of it work yes indeed I wanted to
quickly touch on because I spoke with
Michael Levin recently and I'm also
interested in um the work of Sebastian
Ricci and so these are folks who um talk
about things like morphogenesis and and
emergence and in the context of AI it's
very interesting because you can
potentially have these self-repairing
systems you know like if you so you're
kind of like designing the system to
explicitly transgress the emergence
hierarchy
um you know so so like the actual thing
you're building is an emergent
phenomenon of the underlying thing yeah
and I think there's a loads of potential
there but I just wondered like can can
you think of any interesting crossovers
in into AI along those line
not immediately I must admit I'd have to
ever think about it and maybe a point of
beer I mean I think the stuff that
maybe it's just my my kind of more
applied mind
um because some scientists are not so
obliged and some are
um I think the generative neural
networks are really exciting yeah you
know because
if you understand the code
the Gen you know you can encode that in
a generative neural network and then can
we build things which are actually
useful to humans because I I'm a medical
scientist as well I mean that's I work
in the Institute micro medicine so is
there things there that we can actually
do once we crack the code I don't know
how it got there but we can crack it can
we use it to actually do things with by
bringing in these generative neural
networks to specify bits of function in
bits of DNA which would do useful things
for us yeah so that's the one that kind
of excites me a lot yes um yes but
that's it comes on a little bit
frankensteinian I suppose but you know I
know I mean have you got any thoughts on
um regulating this technology
do you mean AI or well I mean I I guess
that there's a there's a bit of a
crossover into your neck of the woods
but you know when we've got this new AI
act coming into Force saying that you
know like companies like open AI might
have trouble you know productionizing
these very open-ended yeah because you
could use chat GPD to do anything and
the open-ended nature is is because we
always thought there was no friction
between the legal landscape and
technology and um I think in in the
biology world it's far more mature than
it is in the AI world I mean that we've
had
those kind of concerns for a long time
which is why we answered the data
protection act if you sequence
somebody's genome you'd literally have
their blueprint yes so what can you do
with that what can't you do with that
what are the ethics around that that's
been in biology for a very long time
um so if you understand something so say
you do some research and you find
something which might have a real world
sort of effect on a person yeah mutation
or something like that how would you
think about that and there's a there's a
framework in place for all of that and
that's really about
um anonymization often or consent to be
informed or things like that yes
um now you combine it with AI
yeah that's going to get even more
interesting I think I know I know um you
know this nature nurture of discussion
has been going on forever and you just
said you have the blueprint if you have
the DNA and um I guess the implication
there is that you could kind of predict
things about people basically based on
the DNA and I just wondered do you have
any you know you know it's like a
pendulum and you can be one place how
how predictable is stuff from DNA
some things like her color and stuff is
very predictable yeah
um
things like disease icons and this is
where I think the AI comes in because
the way these disease predispositions
that I work on are is we've all got them
yeah we have everybody has got them
they're called common variants for a
reason because they are just very common
and the diseases are common so having
one of these signals will not predispose
you but not predispose you so that's the
wrong word will not condemn you to a
certain disease what it is is
combinations of these signals working
together in very complex ways which we
don't understand yet which will increase
your risk of a given disease and we all
have them for different diseases it
doesn't matter
where you could imagine there's the AI
could with a big enough data set and a
big and I mean sort of medical histories
and their full genetics
could start to learn things like true
risk
and I think that's an important thing we
could do because you could imagine in a
world down the future your genome
getting sequins when you're born
and then actually there is your your
medical
um path could be informed by that risk
but that's a very complex thing to do
Society I mean if you think about just
your insurance alone imagine America if
your insurance company got a hold of
that I mean what would they do with it
you know there's a very complex
interplay between these Technologies and
society and what's right and what's
wrong yeah and there's also a reflexive
property as well because when the
information's out there it might change
but I mean for example now I can get my
genome sequenced and realize I'm at risk
for certain things and take better yeah
some tolerances
um yeah yeah and and also like there's
this thing about
because you can't you can use
statistical approaches but that seems a
little bit brittle there's no analytical
shortcut to directly indicate if someone
has a certain risk potential but I guess
in the future even though there's
unimaginable complexity it might do some
kind of simulations yeah and like you do
a sort of Monte Carlo simulation you see
like all of these trajectories and you
see clusters going all over the place
and then you might you might kind of
like do some statistical assay of that
and say well you've got all these
different clusters and like most of them
are in that cluster therefore you have
this kind of risk yeah and it might you
know it might
um just in the most positive way
thinking about it aside from all the
concerns Society concerns say you had a
risk for skin cancer you know well
put some block on you know don't go live
in Australia or if you do make sure
you're actually very cautious about it
because you have an increase wrist
though to be perfectly honest most of us
know if we come from like uh families
where we we know our our kind of
large-scale family we already know these
risks yeah because it tends to be what
your relatives die off you know I mean
that is the kind of the the basic way of
seeing it is if you see in a family you
know
7 out of 12 adult meals died of heart
attacks well
you know one look at the lifestyle and
two think there is a risk there I mean
so they're not unusual con concepts for
us I think it's formalizing nailing them
down and then actually just making them
across the full Board of risk you know
glioma skin cancer you know Alzheimer's
dementia all of this stuff you know and
what would that do to your mental health
if somebody told you to have a teacher's
like 20. I'd be like I know I'd be a
death sentence wouldn't it but then
everybody would be getting it yeah but
some people will go at the age of 20.
yeah and carry on doing what they're
doing and other people were you know
just
would be worried about that yes so all
of those things have to be thought about
really careful yes what else are you
working on and how can people find out
more about you
um my website is the main place if you
can face and if you're in the mood to
read my reviews and scientific papers
that's where my main product comes out
but obviously they're not there for
easy digesting they're scientific yes
yes documents that reviews hopefully are
a bit more readable I do do public
Outreach
um sort of this is a bit more publicy
Outreach for me yeah um yeah amazing
Professor youth has been an absolute
honor thank you so much it's a pleasure
my first stimulating conversation I do
my very best
wonderful wonderful and
yeah so the channel is machine learning
Street talk yeah mlsd MLS too yeah I
followed another look oh wonderful yeah
yeah
[Music]
um
yeah it's pretty cool it's mostly kind
of yeah computer science machine
learning for a bit of philosophy yeah I
did notice that coming through yes
Christina Neuroscience though yeah well
you know what um I started out because
I've got a machine learning PhD yeah and
it's remarkable when AI how all roads
lead to philosophy
if you're doing it sensibly
yeah I think that's what kind of it's
been such an education for me and just
speaking of all these amazing scientists
like myself because it just made me
realize how much stuff we don't know
that's the pontecho if anybody says we
understand this bloody lying because
it's always that next step that you're
chasing I mean the technological article
we're doing over the last 50 years is
Bonkers yeah I mean absolutely insane
yeah in terms of compute power
we can edit the human genome in a human
you know and cure them of diseases that
have been killing people for Millennia
yeah you know that kind of level of
power
50 years I mean it's just I mean you
know we went through this whole
industrialization technology but we are
literally we're no longer exponential I
think we're pointing straight upwards
you know it's just absolutely bonkers
do you think there are like
because you know like people like um
Express people talk about you know this
kind of recursive super intelligence
recursive self-improvement and so on
yeah like there are always limiting
factors and like science is a great
example so like we're producing
exponentially more papers and we're
seeing kind of like a linear Improvement
in science well again I think that's
slightly to do with the
the way science was done in the past the
way the science is done now selling
science is
almost industrialized to some degree
right
um you go back you know start of the
Royal Society it's sort of generally
Rich geezers running around spending
their wealth on Hobbies which fine but
obviously there was really no chance for
someone like me to do science and higher
now it's a much more democratized thing
and I think it should be yeah it really
should be yeah
um but that just means the complexity
has gone through the roof I mean for me
to even keep up with all the papers in
my own field is nearly impossible so
that system is kind of broken some ways
I mean we need some ways of being able
to digest that knowledge and again that
is probably where these kind of language
models if properly validated and trained
actually could do something for us could
you kind of digest the main point of a
field in a reliable way and guided to
give you that output by recursive in you
know conversations back and forth with
the whoever it is who's doing it
whatever field or whatever subject can
only do that does is there a real future
for chat GTP Beyond a very very good
liar you know
it's not it's not too bad but is there a
risk though because um
we interviewed Sarah hooker and she
talked about a hardware Lottery and she
was talking about how
um most AI research now is kind of like
determined by previous Hardware
decisions that were made a long time ago
so you get these basins of Attraction
yeah you look at all AI research now
it's basically all the same it's
sclerotic and I should know come out I
read loads of AI research it's all
language models it's all just minor
variations on the same thing and
creativity is about like something new
right but creativity is not that common
even even in even in
um you know my working life how many
times have I been creative
a few times yeah I'm also generally sort
of a creative person who actually really
think I did something you know that
those are not that
um common and actually it's a lot of
work to actually capitalize on that
creativity to take it from a spark to
actually something that works and is
useful for whatever you were trying to
do yeah so I think humans are a bit
lemming like you know totally but I mean
partly that's because you know um the
Stepping Stones which lead to Greatness
tend to be pretty strange so there's a
kind of serendipity to creativity and
who's going to be serendipitous when
you're working in Academia and you want
to get your PhD you want to make sure
you get your papers published and you
know like any job there's pressures on
it and you you kind of have to just keep
going with the system to make sure you
get paid next year you know I mean
they're not people have this idea that
you know Academia we're all sitting
around smoking points and Ivory Towers
gazing out the window we're not we're
running around like bloody hamsters on
Wheels just making sure we can pay the
wages and all the rest of it for our
people and our research yeah so there is
an awful lot of churn just to keep the
job going so then you have to squeeze
your creativity into the bureaucracy
um the kind of the day-to-day work the
managing your students you're doing your
HR all that stuff so it ends up squeezed
into quite a small space
so it's not even given a lot of room in
that job as well and I'm sure that's the
same for just about any kind of academic
research
um I read this great book called why
greatness cannot be planned by Kenneth
Stanley and you know he says that it's
all about metrics and objectives so like
you know this consensus because creating
convergence instead of Divergence and
like you know the alternative might be
that you have all these gentleman
scientists in their garages just doing
random you know but I think there is
something intrinsically powerful about
creating Divergent processes yeah and
actually were science works best is when
you have Divergent people in terms of
their trajectory coming from different
places yeah yeah
you know basic things like male female
ratio I mean that should be there
obviously but just diversity of people
because we all because of where we come
from you know where we have even brought
we think of things slightly differently
and that's where creativity comes in you
trying to explain it to somebody who's
not really quite getting it
um or them explaining it to back to you
better then you could exclude it to them
yeah just because people see things in
slightly different points of view and I
think that that's a bit like what Edwin
was talking about that's putting noise
in the system if you have a load of
people who went to the same school will
talk about the same teachers also
sitting in a lab trying to do science is
nowhere near as good as having a rag
type mix of people from all over the
world in the lab yeah I completely agree
although I would I would go and say
diversity preservation rather than
diversity because you can still have a
diverse group of people but if you still
have the same monolithic objectives
there's the same consensus mechanism I
know that might wash away the diet you
know it's almost like there needs to be
something in the process as well as the
people no I agree I mean I think the
problem with the way the world Works in
Academia and actually just the world
full stop is we're always trying to make
they're always trying to give metrics to
things to see how well you've done yeah
and if you've done well enough they give
you a treat which is like some more
money or pay you or something like that
yeah and actually that tends to make you
less noisy if you want to put it in that
yeah it's convergent.com forward slash
convergent exactly yeah and so you need
to be able to put some space into
people's lives and this is actually what
these things are about what we're
sitting here for this is where I've got
a day where I don't have to worry about
bureaucracy or HR or anything I have to
give a talk but find a bit of adrenaline
is good but then you can just talk to
random people and you know we've got
artists and AI people and
microbiologists and neurosciences all
wandering around and then we're going to
have a couple of drinks afterwards and
I'll just make the information flow a
little bit better I know but you know
what because I was speaking with peota
before and he into theater no I enjoyed
this talk it was great it is amazing and
he he actually I think he really
understands something intuitively but
it's very difficult to verbalize because
you know in the in this kind of Western
academic world we we have that you know
we Prime we prize abstract thinking and
um what I'm saying is that washes away a
lot of this subjective creative kind of
you know flow thinking that that artists
have and I think we're really missing a
trick there
um
yes I mean I wouldn't want to paint
That's So black that we're not doing it
I think it could be done better yeah but
if you get a couple of scientists in a
room with nothing else to do what do you
think they're gonna do they're just
going to be bouncing ideas around not
arguing and actually that's the space
where creativity comes in that's that's
true that's true but I mean to to give
an example um in in computer science in
mazes you have an algorithm to to find
this best solution to amaze and
um if it's using as a single objective
so it might have a loss function which
is like you know the kind of the square
distance between your position and the
end those algorithms never work very
well yeah and the best algorithms are
like these evolutionary algorithms where
you have like a diverse set of solutions
and like you know you kind of like
increase the entropy and it's almost
like in in the literature
computer science people have understood
this for ages and it's like so why do we
still have these kind of like consensus
mechanisms all over science
I agree but then there's also the
practice I'm just thinking about it so
my my average day is there is no one
objective
there's 20 objectives yeah a day and
some of them are mundane and some of
them are not one down yeah like you know
make sure I can convince somebody to
keep my alarm going for the next five
years or something like that but you're
also dealing with all of those
objectives at the same time and they
Collide quite creatively you know so
you're trying to think of a good project
for a PhD student you know who's maybe
struggling a little bit or something
like that well actually this is a really
good project and actually has to fit a
criteria like it's got to be we have to
have the data it's got to be easily done
there's no bench work involved it's all
computational or vice versa
and then you're off trying to write you
know grant for the next five years and
then you're going oh actually that these
are really great ideas I came over there
for a completely different reason but it
now fits in a slot that I see over here
where I wanted to try and do something
completely different yeah so that
that does work it's not perfect
but we're not really everybody's not
pointed at one thing and go on go I mean
yes at the high level I want us to
understand how the genome works fine but
so much bits in there and ways of
looking at it and you know that actually
I do think we end up just juggling lots
and lots of different balls yeah I agree
with that and I think um
if I may slightly reframe I don't know
whether whether you would agree with
this but
some of the objectives are written down
and they're the official public facing
objectives and then there's all of the
sub games where nothing's really written
down you know like we have hidden social
rules there's the social game there's
like the politics games this game and
it's almost like you are actually
playing all of these different games and
they kind of mix together in quite an
interesting way
yes
um and again that's part of the the
noise in your normal life yeah you know
so those things all push you and pull
you this way in that way yeah and that
just puts you know you don't come in the
morning going right I'm going to do
genome today you're getting buffeted by
all of these different games Society
people human interactions and they kind
of knock you around all over the place
and I think that is part of what
creativity is I think creativity is
actually being able to positively use
that people who get frustrated by it or
really want to work in a straight line
really struggle to be creative in that
way yes whereas if actually you've just
been through a half hour of beating up
of a talk that you had to get or
something and somebody asked you really
rotten question if you get upset by that
then that's not the right way to do it
the right way to go is think why was
that such a rotten question you know
it's so hard to answer so if I think
it's more of an attitude to some degree
I think creative people have a much more
uh slightly annoying but actually I'll
just keep going you know I'll just think
about that or I'll bring this yeah so
there's a much more positive attitude to
creativity I think I think creativity is
naturally a positive thing it requires a
positive frame of mind I completely
agree and I think another really cool
thing about human cognition is that we
can create links between seemingly very
different things and and it's like it's
analogy making yeah and it's like
there's there's this Infinite Space of
analogy so you can have a very random
experience you know like driving to pick
your kids up from school or whatever and
you can still somehow draw on that
experience if you're a creative person
to influence the other things you're
doing yeah and it's like when I was
talking about the glass uh algae that
was literally me watching somebody and
you know making Glasgow oh it's a bit
like a toxic yeah but they're absolutely
completely different things yeah so that
that kind of sparking in between the
different strands of your life the kind
of normality bits of your life you know
is actually
work creativity comes on most of my
ideas you know any ideas I do have I'm
doing the washing up or more on the lawn
or something I mean but but one one take
on this is that we're just in this kind
of petri dish and there's just all of
this stuff going I guess you can think
of it in terms of free will you know
like
you could think of it as being really
quite random and chaotic yeah um or you
could think of it as saying it's quite
directed and I I have an intention I
have a will and so on
again I think that's impressively I just
um very nosy and I get bored really easy
I mean that that's yeah I do see life as
structured or not you know I'm not
completely insane I do see there is
structure around me there's a lot of
random stuff that happens obviously but
actually I'm just I get I get bored very
easily and I get nosy and my brain just
wanders off in those baths so that I
think that's I maybe I'm not answering
or bouncing off your comment correctly
or going off on a bloody dungeon as you
but yeah I think that's where
um
it's the kind of nosiness I mean there's
no am I trying to save Humanity no I'm
trying to increase the knowledge of
humanity because I'm nosy I mean I'm
curious yeah and I think that's that's
the real driver of a scientist it's just
that and then also the good thing about
that is
you don't actually occur what other
people think about the things you're
nosy about you know and I think that's
where some of the really best Sciences
come from is people just wanting to
understand something that nobody has
given that about until they went look at
this and they went oh actually that's
important and that's adding the noise
because that's you as an individual
following your own gradient of Interest
yeah and not necessarily encumbered by
other people around you and then you
will find an interesting stepping stone
so it's almost like there's this
Intrepid Explorer approach to science
yep and the reason why you're interested
in it you may have read a science
fiction book when you're a 15 and loved
it you may have met somebody on the bus
he was talking about their favorite
hobby or all of those inputs to that
nosiness are also chaotic yeah as well
yeah so you could never really predict
why why am I suddenly interested in this
stuff and start you know so there's a
chaos to that as well amazing Professor
Hughes has been such an honor thank you
so much for coming on Pleasure all right
no I love it that was amazing that's